hey everyone it's Mike from Immortal
flows and welcome back to my channel I'm
glad you could join me for today's video
we're going to be talking about uh
Market exhaustion exhaustion prints in
the market and you know this is actually
one of my favorite uh trade setups that
you know when I first started trading
with order flow
um I I would look for all right so
before I jump in if you've been enjoying
learning from my videos don't forget to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell so you don't miss any new uploads
and if you find today's video helpful
you know be sure to hit that like button
for me and leave a comment sharing your
biggest takeaway you know I love hearing
your feedbacks and oftentimes I do make
videos based off of uh the comments that
you leave you know people asking a
specific question and you know
oftentimes they get questions you know
what's uh what's the best setup to take
in order flow and honestly there you
know the market is
dynamic in the sense that there's
different little nuances
um that you that you see daily day in
day out but there's certain things uh in
the order flow that when I see it I have
a pretty strong conviction of a trade so
let's jump into today's topic all right
Market exhaustion and yeah yesterday you
know I was doing my my weekly live group
training for my order flow users
um people a question had come up about
you know how quickly can someone learn
order flow well
or you know and then the question
expanded on to how long did it take me
to learn order flow and you know I
explained that I had already been in the
market you know by the time I you know
the footprint chart came around
um I had already been in the markets
already I've been uh electronic trading
you know off the floor on the native
Globex terminals from the exchanges and
you know so I was in a sense all that
time already following the order flow
now
um the order flow because you'd have to
work nights right to trade the
electronic sessions back then
um so you know I'd come into the office
around 10 30 at night and leave after uh
8 30 in the morning
s PS This was even before the time of
the minis
um you know the regular s PS would close
at 8 15 then reopen at 8 30 in in the
pit but the volumes that would trade
overnight is nothing compared to the
volumes that you got now so you know it
was a bit easier to watch you know watch
the depth of the market right watch
um you know see what's in there it
wouldn't change that much in the middle
of the night honestly I mean once Europe
opened up yeah obviously more activity
and then you know into the Morning by
the last uh you know from a 6 30 to 8 15
was was the busy time but there were
certain things that stuck with me during
those times and it was really reinforced
by Tom DeMark I used to work with his
nephew
back at Dean Witter and I remember
Tom DeMark had said something he was in
one of his seminars because you know the
one nice thing is I was able to go to
seminars for free back then he had said
when the last buyer has bought
look for the market to reverse or if the
last seller has sold look for the market
to reverse and when I
first understood you know a footprint
chart you know this is over 10 years ago
seeing the volumes then it really became
very clear as opposed to watching time
and sales you know because time and
sales moves fast you know in the old
days we didn't move as fast as it moves
now but you can see what the volumes
traded at a particular price and and to
me this was like well like Earth
shattering so to speak in the sense that
oh you could actually have it on your
chart you know on your footprint chart
and
when I was trading you know even before
we started up order flows and all that
stuff you know and I was just trading on
a footprint chart myself this is one of
the things that I would look for
specifically and especially you know in
the currencies you you don't get them as
often in a market like the e-minis just
because it's
um
trades a lot more volume but you know
majority markets currencies
um
crude oil the metals like gold you could
see that in there grains even
um and it's what we term as the
exhaustion print we just call it small
print you know 10 years ago we've sort
of changed the name to exhaustion print
to accurately reflect it and really what
you're doing is you're looking at the
edges of candles what's the volume
coming in and where do you want to look
at these well after a move after a move
up if the last buyer has bought what do
you expect the market to do expect it to
reverse all right just as you know if a
market is selling off and the last
seller has sold
what do you expect the market to do
expect it to Rally right because there's
no more selling pressure on a move down
or there's no more buying pressure on a
move up
okay and I I would just spend the day
you know looking at the footprint chart
when it's
before we had the overflows Trader
software because I wasn't even you know
I was just using someone else's
footprint and
I just sit there I would specifically
look for these situations where I get
this volume up here one contract okay
down here one contract now there was a
one here okay started to go up still
just a little bit of selling Market came
down then boom
you get your your next signal here and
then the market has a nice rally and
this is sort of how the order flow
Traders software came about is because
I remember sitting there thinking you
know this this sucks you know it's like
I got to keep my eye on the screen why
can't I have a software
that does it for me that just highlights
it to me okay and in the order flow
Trader software right that's why we have
all these functions in here right these
are functions that I created based on my
own trading experience that I'm looking
for in the market and exhaustion prints
right here you know you can set your
limit I have it set at one draw until
tested just to highlight it out you
click apply and it just makes it much
more visual right to it to a Trader you
want to see these things as soon as they
happen you know it's not necessarily a
red light green light system but more of
a whack upon the side of your head
system saying hey don't miss this so if
I'm watching the market and I see the
market you know
and here we are going up pulls back a
little bit and we've got exhaustion
print there of one contract pulls back
one one one okay this one yeah I
probably would have taken to as the
market starts ticking back up this one
no because it doesn't go any higher but
if I took this first one yeah you'd
stopped out fine because where you're
going to place your stop we're just
behind this other line because if you're
saying this is exhaustion right this one
contract is exhaustion if we trade below
that it's not exhaustion
okay but you're not just getting long
because you have an exhaustion print you
still want to see the order flow start
to tick up in the next couple of bars
which it does so yeah it gets stopped
out here this one market doesn't tick up
so
you're not taking that trade you do get
stopped out on that first one but then
again you get this next one here
new swing low this one's not really even
a swing low but this one is
start ticking up that's your go sign all
right you take the trade market rallies
up you get up here to a swing High one
contract trades okay so if you're along
from there this is your sign to get out
the market starts ticking down even in
the next bar another exhaustion print
and the market sells back off down to
where
you had that exhaustion print earlier
okay
um
you know here's another one I mean I I'm
not necessarily a big fan of taking
these in the middle of moves I like it
when a market had just made a move and
then you you see them popping in if
there's any more later after that I mean
this one came in here was a new high
right here Market starts trading down
but then it just goes sideways so that's
not one you're going to take and again
this is Euro currency now you know other
markets British pound for example
um you know today
British pounds I mean Bank of England
sort of surprised the markets I guess by
keeping rates unchanged for the first
time in two years
you know these central banks in my
opinion they do communicate with each
other
um obviously the FED did nothing
yesterday so you know
we had that big sell-off here today in
the pound and where is it
boom right there but afterwards right
you see the market goes up pulls back
it's not a swing low but in the bar
right after the swing low again I could
accept it that this coming in on the bar
right after the swing low okay get a
nice little rally putting a swing High
exhaustion print there
but that's a little far removed
um again another swing low another
exhaustion print right here
and you could just you just start you
start seeing these exhaustion prints
then watch what the market does after it
puts it in okay because that's going to
give you your clue
um
let's take a look at crude oil today I
haven't looked at crude yet this morning
but um
let's just take a look pull it up
okay and you can see right here right is
this a swing High well that's your swing
high again a couple here again I'd much
rather prefer it at a swing high like
here
or here but right here is kind of in the
middle of sideways activity right you
want to you know people always say you
know trade in context of the markets
okay
you know this one would you take well
again it's it's yeah you just made a new
high is two bars later
I I don't know I'd rather it be right on
the high or the bar afterwards that's
just me
um
you know here you get a little bit of a
pullback coming in right here it gets
the high starts coming off
but like I said in a market like e-minis
okay now the one thing to note
I do have this one set pretty
tight at just one contract okay and
so let's see here okay so it's a one
contract right one now you could adjust
it to whatever you want right so on a
market that trades more volume like
e-minis
right one is going to be difficult
because it just trades a ton of volume
compared to the euro currency or British
pound so
if you were to change it
to you know you can change it to five
right you can see here limit
means the the volume
um
you know originally when I would use to
use it
um you know 10 years ago I had a volume
of 10 or 9 rather but to show you right
you can set it to a level like five
you could use 10 if you want
but this in this case I'll just set it
to five
and again you know where's the cash open
right here okay going down not a swing
low kind of a swing low
here technically since the cash opened
okay Market starts going up and it's
just sort of going sideways then it
starts falling down again okay would I
take this one again here's a six but
it's not the I set it at five
I was not giving you a signal then you
get down here okay so even if you took
this one
okay it goes up comes down trades down
through that level stops you out fine
live with it
deal with it take your lick your wounds
look for the next trade here on the low
of the day 43 98 and three quarters
first time you trade 45 second time 44
and then four so you keep pounding into
this low selling is getting a bit lesser
and lesser
okay
he leaves that exhaustion print
and you get this nice rally all the way
you know almost uh all the way up to 14.
okay
and you gotta swing High here one two
bars later you get that three
or four rather
um you can see the market sold off now
if you're Trading
much more liquid Market
10 years 10 years is trades a ton of
volume
right I mean volume at a lot of these
prices
uh the wrong tenure symbol there was an
easy and
um but I like to use a four range chart
the reason being I like to use a range
based chart on the market like 10 years
is because of this right it's just a lot
of
trading the bid in the offer right food
price levels in a bar and it just in my
opinion doesn't give you a whole heck of
a lot to go off of that's why I I've
always used
say always but over the last 10 or 15
years a full range chart in treasuries
okay
here you had a two
write off the right off the low starts
going up going sideways sideways but you
can see the selling pressure in this
case sort of building up again
that we may go lower right you can see
11 106 finally breaks through six
thousand almost seven thousand contracts
into the new low and then bounces back
up
but you can see here since last night
the reopen trades four okay sells off
comes back up
sells off comes back up and this swing
low here or so I swing High lower high
but in the next bar you get a one one
contract trades 4 955 contracts in this
bar trade you only got a one
right and again you can see here
yesterday
right low of the day new low of the day
five contracts
shoot straight up
okay
that was during the FED announcements
but you sort of get the idea now of what
you can look for in exhaustion prints
and you don't you could set it to
whatever you want so on a market like
you know this is 10 years right maybe
you don't want to use five you only want
to use you know a higher number
I mean you can set it to whatever you
want it's actually you know honestly you
can set it to
pull it up here I mean you know if you
wanted to you could set it to 50. now
you're going to get a bunch more signals
obviously at 50 because it's quite
strong
all right we can see here right here
here going up
um you know obviously on the way down
but again you can set it to whatever you
want
based off of the market that you're
trading the chart type that you're
trading but really what you're looking
for
is that exhaustion right
really quick
ly so I'll just show you you know he
Hogs okay I'm not gonna set it to 50 on
Hogs
but
you know people like wow Hogs who trades
Hogs actually some of these markets out
there
um
they're worth a look at right they don't
they're not as active as say
obviously minis the volume is much
lighter
but you know you can sort of see these
things I mean it's right off the open
one contract through the low one
contract swing High one contract right
you know it's just it's just fascinating
how it works in the sense of identifying
exhaustion again you know this is a this
is a very thin Market
okay so once you understand that
you get the idea right of how to look
for exhaustion you're looking for the
last Trader to trade
so anyway guys I don't want to go any uh
down any rabbit holes for you guys that
you don't want to go I'll end it there
for now and I'll catch you guys on the
next video so if you haven't already be
sure to subscribe to the channel take
care everyone bye-bye